today we're going to talk about how not
to prepare for law school so stick
around and get a head start here at
legal eagle we've talked a lot about
what you should do before you start law
school so you can get a head start and a
leg up on your classmates which is
really important because you're going to
be graded on a curve so every advantage
you can get is important but there's a
lot of bad information out there and
there's a lot of mistakes you can make
before starting law school here are some
of the worst things that you can do
before starting law school so the first
thing you should not do before starting
law school is you should not read your
case book this is a case book it's a
compilation of all the cases that you're
going to read in your class now the last
thing that you should do is start
opening it up and reading inside number
one you're not going to cover everything
that's in the book number two every
professor is different so even different
professors would use the same case in
different ways and you're going to have
to learn how your particular professor
uses that case book now on top of that
if you did start reading it a lot of the
cases wouldn't make a lot of sense
that's because the law needs to be
interpreted sometimes you use the facts
from a certain case as a point of
reference sometimes you only use
bright-line rules and you ignore the
facts and it's up to your professor to
tell you what's important to take away
from every particular case in addition
it's really complicated stuff and there
are hundreds of books that are out there
to help digest that material looks like
commercial supplements and commercial
outlines so digging into your case book
well it might seem like a good idea and
a good way to get ahead is actually a
terrible idea it's just going to create
more stress and speaking of commercial
outlines don't read those either here's
the commercial outline from Gilbert's
on torch a commercial outline contains a
summary of a particular subject in this
case torts but it's a bad idea to sit
down and read those - first of all it's
hundreds of pages long
are big pages it would be a huge task to
try and read through it and you have at
least three substantive courses every
semester you're not going to get through
it and even if you did you probably
wouldn't really understand it even it's
broken down components and again you
have to understand the law as your
professor presents it to you your
professor is the one that's going to be
giving you a final exam and that
professor is going to write their final
by themselves so it's really important
to understand the law as your professor
gives it to you now
we love commercial outlines and
supplements at legal they play a very
vital role when you're studying for
class but the summer before law school
starts is not the right time to read it
it's a recipe for disaster it's just not
worth it which leads me to my third
point don't try understanding the law
before you get to law school it would
take an incredibly long time lawyers
spend their entire careers learning very
small portions of the law and any
advantage you would have in learning the
substantive law would quickly be erased
as people started boning up themselves
on the law itself which leads me to my
next point don't freak out Law School is
a very stressful time no doubt about it
but it's also wonderful
you'll meet great people you will
stretch yourself academically in ways
that you didn't think you were capable
of you will learn things that you had no
idea existed every day you're going to
learn something new and if you play your
cards right in law school you're going
to have a great time and it's going to
be worthwhile I can tell you as a
practicing trial attorney it was an
incredibly worthwhile experience and I
would do it again if I had to which
brings me to my final tip don't do
nothing now sure it's tempting to just
sit back on a beach and relax before you
start law school but now is the time
where you really can get a head start
and you get a head start not by studying
the law but by studying law school
itself so many people go into law school
not knowing anything about the process
itself and specifically they don't know
anything about how to take law school
exams but law school exams are kind of
like the LSAT
there are strategies and there are
tactics to do better and you can
practice those tactics ahead of time in
our video on the two pillars of law
school success we talked about how you
have to both master the law and master
the tests in law school
everybody masters the law in law school
but so few people put in the time to
learn how to take law school exams well
and when your entire grade is based on
one single exam it's so important to
learn how to do that exam so while it's
tempting to just sit back don't do
nothing before you start law school so
there you go those are the things you
should not do before starting law school
hopefully that helps before you begin
you'll have a great time it's definitely
worth it and from everyone here at legal
eagle remember to study smart through
law school oh and one last thing if
you're getting ready for law school
check this out
we put together a free ebook called the
ultimate free law checkers just click
the link below to download it some of
our best tips and strategies for getting
ahead before you start law school and it
will put you miles ahead of your
classmate just click below and also if
you like this video please subscribe to
our Channel we come out with new videos
on how to crush law school all the time
so thanks a lot thanks for stopping by
[Music]
[Music]